let's start with the star of the show
The Boy Who Lived the one and only Harry
Potter you're a wizard Harry in the
first film of the franchise Daniel
Radcliffe took on the titular role
surprising fans with his ability to
capture the character from the series
the actor was just 11 years old when he
began playing Harry and going back to
that first movie is like a time capsule
for fans how cute was he but if Harry
had have started at Hogwarts a few years
earlier not much would have changed baby
Harry still has the classic messy MAA
hair awkwardly large glasses and an
endearing smile okay now we're seriously
into the idea of a Hogwarts preschool
prequel am I right